[Música]
mi hijo tiene cuatro años y le encanta
saltar en decisión yo le explico que se
puede lastimar y le pido que por favor
no lo haga
mira mira papá dice y sigue saltando y
siempre está a punto de romperse la
cabeza contra la mesa ratona entonces le
gritó goran mi hijo se llama goran goran
deja de saltar su mismo y cuando declaró
ese grito tampoco me da bola
ahora imaginemos esta otra situación mi
hijo está saltando arriba abajo arriba
abajo y de pronto se resbala y está muy
cerca de partirse el cráneo contra la
punta de la mesa ratona así que yo su
padre fuerte y valiente me arrojo y no
salgo lo traigo al piso y después de
chequear que el nene esté bien
le digo goran tenemos que hablar
lo tomó de la mano y lo llevó a dar un
paseo
imaginemos que no estamos en mi casa
estamos en una inmensa pradera en áfrica
imaginemos también que arriba nuestro
hay un cielo estrellado
imaginemos que de pronto
en una orquesta
goran estoy muy decepcionado de ti mes o
venciste deliberadamente te podrías
haber lastimado pero papá yo quería ser
valiente como tú
yo soy valiente cuando debemos ser
valientes gran veras ser valiente no
significa ponerte en peligro pero papá
no le tiene miedo a nada
hoy tuve miedo
de veras si hoy tuve miedo de que te
pasara algo a ti
y en el momento en que termino mi frase
mi pequeño hijo ve la huella de muerte y
es en el suelo y la compara con la de su
zapatilla y entonces recuerda tenido el
doble de peso cinco veces más que llevo
en esta tierra 32 años más que él y que
se número 32 nunca se va a achicar hasta
el día en que yo me muera
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no es lo mismo
no es lo mismo porque esto que acabo de
hacer es una escena del rey león'
los dibujos animados con música con
personajes con historias transmiten
mensajes y lo hacen de un modo muy
potente nos sentimos en el cuerpo
cuando era chico mi película favorita
era el rey león la veía todo el tiempo
el región de una frase que me encanta en
la canción que dice hakuna matata
hakuna matata significa sin problemas en
swahili y también es una filosofía que
el pequeño simba adopta con su padre
muere el leoncito está lleno de culpa
sino de angustia y que hace adopta una
filosofía de vida que más o menos dice
sin preocuparse es cómo hay que vivir
sin embargo cuando crecí y tuve un hijo
y volvía a ver el rey león'
descubrí que calcula matata es
simplemente una etapa en la vida de
simba
vivir en el bosque con tus amigos
comiendo bichos sin preocuparte por
absolutamente nada que no sea tu deseo y
tu libertad
pero lo que sin va realmente tiene que
hacer es asumir sus responsabilidades
volver con su manada ocupar el lugar de
su padre derrotar al mal y restablecer
el ciclo de la vida
esto es el opuesto absoluto de hakuna
matata
el rey león me dijo a los diez años cómo
iban a ser mis veinte y con que los iba
a superar a los treinta
a mi hermana le gustaba la sirenita no
sabía todas las canciones ahora dice que
la sirenita no le gusta mucho porque
ninguna mujer debería entregar su voz
por nombre
yo creo que mi hermana no volvió a ver
la sirenita de grande porque en la
película la princesa ariel quiere estar
con el príncipe eric pero vive reprimida
por el poder patriarcal del rey tritón
es verdad entrega su voz pero es un acto
desesperado y no es hasta que recupera
la voz que puede estar con el chico que
ella quiere en la sirenita la mujer muda
nunca logra lo que quiere
además ariel es un personaje que en toda
la película nunca jamás afloja con su
deseo y en esa aventura logra que su
padre cambie de parecer
la sirenita en la historia del deseo
femenino sexual reprimido que tiene que
salir y el poder masculino que tiene que
hacerse a un lado y escuchar
cuanto de la incomodidad de mi hermana
con los mandatos patriarcales tuvo que
ver con la sirenita cuanto de las
decisiones que tome en mi vida tuvieron
que ver con el rey león'
cada vez que hablo de esto en la radio o
cualquier cualquier lado acá es que
hablo de la filosofía y los dibujos
animados viene alguien y dice no tienen
mensaje son comerciales
son comerciales si ganan millones de
dólares pero pueden hacerlo porque
tienen un contenido filosófico
una película como frozen por ejemplo que
costó 150 millones de dólares sin contar
la promoción está obligada a ser
significativa además de los dibujos
además de las canciones además de la
enorme maquinaria de promoción está
obligada a resonar con el tiempo
histórico que le ha tocado y frozen lo
hace
se mete en la discusión feminista sobre
las princesas y que hace cole proactivas
y las aleja del amor romántico todo sin
tocar los zapatitos los vestidos y las
coronitas
los dibujos animados forman una visión
del mundo
esto ya lo dijeron en el año 71 los
autores dorfman mattelart en su libro
clásico de la filosofía para leer al
pato donald
así se llama
ese libro tiene un capítulo final con
una frase que me encanta y que dice
mientras su cara risueña deambula
inocentemente por las calles de nuestro
país mientras donald sea poder y
representación colectiva el imperialismo
y la burguesía podrán dormir tranquilos
para estos autores el enemigo número uno
el socialismo era un pato sin pantalones
y tenían razón porque la guerra entre el
socialismo y el pato donald la ganó el
pato
pasaron ya 50 años de este libro
muchos de los valores con los cuales se
criticaba a disney en los 70 desde la
izquierda fueron absorbidos por el mismo
disney y por toda la industria del
entretenimiento infantil
se decía por ejemplo que disney era
racista pero los ochentas y los 90 junto
con los protagonistas blancos y
cristianos aparecieron judíos musulmanes
gitanos y chinos y luego aparecieron
mexicanos afroamericanos y polinesios
incluso hoy hace muy poquito tenemos una
película como su utopía que es
básicamente un gran argumento anti
racista
se decía que disney era misógino
y si bien las princesas de los 90 eran
románticas ya estaban empoderadas ariel
como vimos lucha por su deseo
la bella de la bella y la bestia' y
rechaza al macho gastón que muere
asesinado y doma la bestia jazmín de
aladdin cambia las leyes del sultán y
pocas bonitas aún estando enamorada de
john smith decide quedarse en la tierra
de sus ancestros
incluso la diversidad sexual está
incluida en el disney de los 90
mullan por ejemplo es la historia de una
chica que se mete en la guerra
travestida de balón y que gana esa
guerra apoyado por un grupo de varones
travestidos de mujer
su trama de amor es indiscutiblemente
bisexual e incluso podríamos decir que
es queer
y al final de la película moulin recibe
la bendición de su familia de sus
ancestros y del mismísimo emperador de
china
en 2001 se estrenó flec
y con esa película se abrió una puerta
muy interesante la de los discriminados
las tres grandes sagas de dreamworks
shrek kung fu panda' y cómo entrenar a
tu dragón' tienen héroes feos gordos y
personas con discapacidad
hasta la manera en que el bien y el mal
están tratados en las películas
infantiles cambio ya casi no tenemos más
los malvados malísimos incluso películas
donde no hay malos como intensamente o
wally
hay películas en las cuales el malo se
pregunta por su lugar en el mundo y
cambia como mi villano favorito o
megamente
figuras históricamente aterradoras como
ogros monstruos vampiros de pronto son
personajes con temas personales
esta manera de enfrentar los conflictos
la llamé la post maldad
sin embargo hay un argumento de paralela
al pato donald que todavía sigue en pie
cincuenta años después hay un conflicto
que permanece silenciado
y ese es el conflicto de clase social
desde el 90 para acá hay una sola
película que trata directamente el tema
de la pobreza y esa película es aladdin
aladdin es un muchacho pobre ya graba
que vive y convive con niños famélicos
al final de la película cambia la
situación de la dim cambia también la
situación de jazmín la mujer pero los
pobres siguen siendo pobres
tanto en la versión del 92 como en la
remake de 2019 al final de la película
hay un palacio opulento lleno de
riquezas y afuera hay niños muriéndose
de hambre
las películas animadas producidas en
eeuu y consumidas en el mundo entero son
fuertemente progresistas en lo que
respecta al género el racismo la
discriminación la discapacidad la gordo
fobia y son conservadoras con respecto a
los conflictos de clase social
no me sorprendería en los próximos diez
o quince años se impusiera esta visión
del mundo
el capitalismo feminista multirracial
sexualmente diverso e inclusivo donde la
diferencia entre ricos y pobres es cada
vez más grande
porque en disney en dreamworks en
illumination en pixar se reflejan y
también se instalan los valores de
nuestra civilización estas películas no
son inocentes
pero tampoco son el enemigo podemos
usarlas a nuestro favor pero para que
eso suceda hay que entenderlas y para
entenderlas necesitamos un nuevo enfoque
crítico
para ver qué películas de los chicos
para discutirlas entre nosotros y luego
con ellos y sobre todo para saber qué
voces y qué valores están siendo
silenciados
pero volvamos a mi decisión yo tengo un
hijo de 4 años quiero que deje de saltar
así que lo llamo goran ven y por favor y
bajó hasta su altura
de una pregunta sin ti ni la pata más
grande
simba como falsa mufasa
vamos a tu mano la mía
quien tiene una mano más grande vos o yo
vos
entender que si saltas en el sillón te
puedes romper la cabeza
si papá entonces me vas a hacer caso
si papá
los chicos
están sentados en este sillón mirando
dibujos animados
nosotros creemos que es entretenimiento
están embobados pero están sentados
frente a la maquinaria ideológica más
potente de nuestro siglo no nos dejemos
solos
[Aplausos]
[Música]